there's definitely pluses right like
there's things that i get to do because
people recognize my face
or have a um a predetermined opinion of
me
even before we meet so it makes our
encounter
far more positive than their average
encounter with
any other person like i get an instant
icebreaker which is very helpful
in conversations i wouldn't say i'm
socially awkward but i'm not
um i've definitely spent my life
overcoming all those basic social fears
right uh
and so being recognizable helps shortcut
a little bit of that and it also gives
me a bit of a magic power
um in conversations to make people
smile or laugh which is one of my
favorite things to do me too
sure yeah you know downsides are that um
you can't really have a good day uh
that's ready and let me let me
let me say it like this i heard um
god in an interview in the late 90s
uh pep from sultan peppa she said the
hardest part about being famous is you
can't have a public bad day
right because the millionth time
you meet an excited fan is the
only time that fan meets you
wow and so what do you want that moment
to be
i think about that all the time like i
don't need to let it dominate i
i when i when i first started getting
recognized i really i couldn't help
myself but to
cater to it i felt such an incredible
responsibility to make that person's
experience so significant that i would
neglect my actual friends or family
that i was in the middle of hanging out
with and i had people
people became so bold man like i was in
the middle of slow dancing with a
girlfriend on a beach
and somebody literally got between us
and put their hands on either of our
shoulders and was like yo can we take a
picture
jeez i became a stall man in the
bathroom
because so many creepers when
the camera phone
became invented by world james and when
someone like puts their
phone above your toilet style you're
like what what do you want out of this
they want to see poop maybe
i had that once i was in a i was at a
concert
not too long ago i think it was chicago
or something i was seeing the band
chicago
uh they're still around and uh you know
we're i'm in there and the guy goes he
looks at me goes
i know you man i'm like yeah what's
going on he's like yeah man can we get a
picture i go hey can we have a
conversation
after i'm done holding my dick he's like
oh yeah man yeah
yeah and it was cool but it was just
like i mean i am holding my penis
urinating in a stall
can you wait a minute i could
but it would be it wouldn't be as good a
story it would be as good a store as the
next loser was holding his dick
look at this picture of us with our
dicks this is great
why does it always go back to that
accent i grew up in indianapolis
man tell me so i can't be like i was
looking at lex luthor's dick see
we could flip the script right now and
become a more woke hollywood if we just
started doing
less derisive impersonations
you